hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey I am so excited to
cover this video I love when mighty
racoon does this Deadpool invades
Avengers end game trailer number two
this came out a day or two ago actually
here we are now let's hop into this
[Music]
[Music]
okay go ahead we're trailers here it is
your fault
your superpowers
we will my ass
you really practicing their gun skills
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh nice mighty nice great job again dude
I noticed in this one not every shot was
only superimposing Deadpool's face on to
the other characters heads and I
probably has to do with the fact of how
it one of your opening jokes was this
dimple [ __ ] is getting boring right in
reference to
oh this Deadpool thing must be getting a
little old now or getting boring this is
a nice way to mix it up I don't know if
you're friends with aldo jones or not
this felt a little bit in tune with like
an aldo jones weird trailer in a lot of
ways which i really liked but i thought
it was actually really smart to just
kind of have Deadpool off on the side
for half of this just commentating or
being in this scene with them as opposed
to just superimposing the face but then
of course having some moments where the
Deadpool face is being superimposed onto
the Marvel heroes yeah i man seeing them
all on the quantum suits just always
Deadpool together I think my favorite
moment out of the entire thing was when
he's summoned Stormbreaker and just
whacks him in the back of the head and
yeah that is like a very sort of Aldo
Jones kind of insertion I also thought
it was funny the recurring joke about
how he keeps to him like aim for the
chest and then when it doesn't work he's
like yeah I told him totem cam I think
it'd actually be funnier to see Deadpool
in this world and this setting of after
the Avengers have failed and then you
have Deadpool there to make fun of them
for their fuck-ups I feel like that
would actually be a much funnier version
no Deadpool in the MCU than any other
possibility because he can literally
just make them feel terrible the entire
time but he has good points so really
life tight the Scarlett Johansson firing
the gun thing cuz as cool as it is in
both the Super Bowl spot and the second
trailer it is that thing of what's that
gonna do for you shoot down a bunch of
somebody got like some special it's good
like badasses equivalent of kryptonite
in there what hey what's in the bullets
that you're gonna be able to really
provide that makes this different you
know well you know they'll make a bullet
out of each Infinity stone and that's
how they'll eventually kill ya shooting
him so yeah I thought the physical gags
are really cool of Deadpool getting hit
like when you guys
by hawkeye's daughter's arrow practicing
archery like that was an unexpected
moment and of course some of the
superimposing was very realistic the
whole thing with NASSCO and over
Deadpool's mask
I actually thought looked very real I
was kind of wondering if that was some
after-effects thing you did or if you
actually you know did that you got a
mask on and you put a Captain America
mask over because it looks but looks
pretty realistic to me especially when
I'm just looking at it still love it
right now yeah it's really good this
comes out of perfect timing with the
Disney Fox merger right around the
corner and just like a couple days this
is not far off from being an actual
reality sometime soon my friend sometime
soon which is what this video made me
think about and it made me start to
wonder like how would Deadpool in turn
because like you know that we've had
cause to think about it so much but this
is the first time I've really been like
what would Deadpool look like in the MCU
and do I want that to happen yeah you
know do I want him to stay in his own
little side world or do I want him here
kind of just deflating all the situation
like what would Deadpool do to help the
Avengers if he was just part of the
overall shared world I don't feel like
MCU characters in the Deadpool movie
would work I don't know if Deadpool in
MCU movie will work that's kind of just
my stance on the whole matter if that's
a good stance and I also think you and
Aldo Jones must collide I don't know if
you guys have collided together yet but
it's a must-do collab it up do it
immediately before we wrap this up I
would like to give a patron the day
shout out to a fairly new patron of ours
his name I asked him specifically how to
pronounce it Eve Janie and if Jenny have
junior Evgeny
if Guinea he said they just call him
Chevy so I'm gonna call you Jeffy Jeff
Eco a Chevy lives all the way in Malta
which is a small island surrounded by
the sea in larger countries and he
actually has his own little reaction
channel going on - you guys should go
check it out right away
I subscribe to it Evgeny Khurana Khurana
that's just his name and he does do a
really good job on the reaction videos
and I'll also say that when I was
talking to him I found out that his
passion is actually in law he is very
passionate about it because of some
injustice that was done to his uncle and
because of that he believes in fighting
the good fight I mean a lot of people
here just want to go into law for the
money and this is a dude that when I
asked him
like words his passion for law come from
he had a very personal route into why so
I hope that you can become a lawyer in
the States and that I could hire you
because lord knows I'm gonna get sued
any minute now
for it countless things I've done and I
could use a good lawyer
right about now hurry up get on that
little canoe that you have that your
whole Island shares row your way twenty
thousand miles across the sea get to
America which will take you to New York
and then travel by bus to California do
it right away thank you for being here I
need your help now
subscribe to mighty raccoon subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification about a check it's not a
patreon I got so many goodies CEO